[Music]
the BMW factory in Spartanburg South
Carolina has been producing cars for
twenty years what made the German
carmaker head across the Atlantic and
set up shop in the USA the i-team and
AMA BMW is followed Krueger says there
were three reasons the company saw a
great potential because of market growth
in America
another important reason was that it
meant BMW could generate profits in the
USA without being affected by changes in
the exchange rate between the euro and
the dollar the third reason was that the
company believed the SUV market would
continue to develop and therefore by
starting production in the USA
the BMW brand would also develop Nevada
marker on the bean people vitalica the
factory celebrated its 20th anniversary
with the release of the new x4 which is
being produced exclusively at the
Spartanburg plant it's a smaller version
of the x6 and is set to take on the
compact crossover SUV market
[Music]
the x-series began with the x5 back in
1999 the x3 and x6 followed and the cars
aren't just made for the American market
about 70% of them are exported to more
than 130 countries around the world
including Germany the differences
between the two countries meant BMW had
to come up with a new approach here
[Music]
Athens live Carl Kruger says it's
important for every employee to have
quality as their top priority BMW has to
invest more in education and training in
the USA than in Germany America doesn't
have the same training programs as
Germany so people applying for jobs here
often don't have the necessary
qualifications but he says each side can
learn from the other the Americans are
flexible and positive and really engaged
with what's going on when the IMF
biden's items 8a tubular
the factory produced almost 300,000 cars
in 2013 some of the decisions on
production are also made here
the Invicta with dental and most of the
development takes place in Germany at
the research and engineering Center the
American factory takes over when
production starts
but Heartland says some of the decisions
are made right here the factories
running while people are asleep in
Germany so people here need to be able
to make decisions quickly each series
has a development team here in
Spartanburg all four local if I come
from different movie there's close
contact between the two countries
rolling Gore moves from Munich to
Spartanburg to help run things here he's
responsible for planning the production
of the x4
in Portland Rowland says a team from the
factory went over to Germany during the
planning phase for the explore the
Americans who went are now back in the
USA working on production it's an active
exchange between Americans and Germans
had a great network has grown out of
that I'm told it's like a vaccine
Charles Jeffrey is another key figure
here he thinks the production team is
more closely connected to the creative
process than it would be at other
companies
I think the biggest difference is just
the innovations and the involvement with
the planning and development side of the
product so we don't just build the
products here we're also part of the
development process with our partners in
Munich and the global network that we
have with the other factors Anthony
Brown started in BMW straight after
finishing his studies he says he's
learned a lot about language and culture
through working for the car maker 20
years ago for me there was nothing here
we actually made the plant for the first
time you know constructing everything in
the main line and I was able to join the
original team to build the very first
318 it was awesome for me being so young
to start with BMW at a very early age
you know deep-rooted Bavarian sometimes
you know is it's difficult for the
Americans to understand the Bavarians
when they are speaking but you know but
that's just the culture you know so it
takes time and I guess much more and
more practice I guess will make it
better after 20 years the factory is
still growing BMW is investing a billion
dollars here and boosting the number of
employees they want to make even more
cars in Spartanburg